all right let's go into spinal
displacement
um we know we have three training
components spiritual energetic SL
alchemical the reason I slash it is
because neither one is really
right okay so I kind of just they're
working terms and the assumption is
you're training with me you'll you'll
learn what they are through
experience and then the third component
is the physical
Marshall
um spinal displacement functions in each
one of those
components and of course differently
thereby but Al but concentrically so
they feed each
other at the physical Marshall
side when we look at iido kihon waza and
we remember that iido Kaza is not iido
it's a subset of
iido so when we look at iido
Kaza from the physical slm Marshal point
of
view spinal displacement is the Tactical
opening for iido
Kaza there there is no
iido
Kona that makes Marshall sense with
without spinal
displacement so all of Yama and they
standing still and trying to grip in
place this this makes no Marshal sense
whatsoever just punch that
in the face you you don't
need any kind of non-c contestation or a
Reconciliation of Yin and yangong you
don't you already at
Yin hit that
to try to gain some sort of mechanical
leverage from somebody who's just
standing there is just
stupid now sometimes some people of
course a lot of people don't realize
that and some of you don't either
because you're sending me videos and
you're you're clearly your UK are not
pushing and this goes back to like if if
you want to do what I'm doing you have
to do what I do that means you're going
to have to stop doing what everyone else
is doing so sure the rest of the iido
world does not do spinal
displacement but the rest of the iido
world also doesn't have the internal
aspects they don't have the martial
aspects they don't have the spiritual
aspects it all goes
together now some people think that
there was some great Marshall problem
from the guy that was just standing
still and some of you have made this
comment before where I could tell you
think like
this so you think that's a greater
Marshall problem than the person who's
pushing through and that is just not
true the greater Marshall problem is
spinal displacement because in real life
spinal displacement actually functions
it
works n out of 10 times just charge that
person they're going to lose they cannot
handle the violence of
action they cannot handle the increased
inertia The increased momentum The
increased Force the shorter opening in
terms of
timing and the reduced availability of
space they cannot handle it it is a much
more difficult Marshal problem spinal
displacement is than just sitting there
anchoring down down and having someone
try to gain leverage over your wrist
when that's not a marshall problem again
because you would just hit that
person so martially tactically that's
the opening for iido Kon waza and then
Marsh tactically that is the more
difficult problem more difficult
tactical response to address
energetically you need the spinal
displacement because all of the
energetic SL
alchemical processes is a
manipulation of what in essence is a
Grace that is bestowed upon
you at at the spiritual component the
the deconstruction of the ego tripartite
mind and the rising of the God God mind
is not something you do it is a passive
reception of
something that is on the west end of the
sil Road they call that
Grace on the East End they called it
Wu the middle component of the energetic
alchemical is a manipulation of those
natural
processes for the purposes only of
bringing agency to that Grace
State that's
it and so you have to you have to
artificially
generate the grace State and you do that
through Yang
aspect which is manifested through
spinal displacement
so there's
no agency induced formation of the lower
tonden without the Yang aspect itself
being
manipulated through agency and that is
spinal displacement you need to have
spinal displacement so going back for
example in the cultivation drill
set I've made two recent videos where
you're UK just they're just not pushing
hard enough they're just
not you have they have to push harder
you're only deceiving
yourself and
secondarily it won't
concentrically and successfully address
the Tactical opening for Kon Wasa or the
Marshal serious problem of an assaulter
spinally displacing
you so one I we're going to do a
discovery uh learning here and I I would
like for you to do it and you'll see
what I
mean when you're spinally
displacing all of the related manifested
forces they all
increase with the increase of those
forces the likelihood that you will
internalize them and non-contest goes
way
down the likelihood that you will
externally brace upon them or against
them and contest them goes way up
because it's a harder Marshal
problem the wind window of opportunity
is
smaller in size and in duration it is
shorter so your my is only a glimmer and
then the technique is
gone so again when your UK is not
pushing in the cultivation set and we're
probably just practicing ego Tri partite
uration
self-deception we are probably doing
doing that in kihon waza
too we don't want to
address what needs to be addressed our
lack of skill yet
cultivated okay so we did we've done two
exercises looking or two techniques from
the point of view of the anatomical
positioning contained therein meaning
you can't just move any old way
the architecture of each K MAA is very
specific so we we did eeko and we did
kokun and uh we're going
to uh up the spinal displacement and
that's that's what I want you to do for
your own Discovery learning and watch
your Technique go out the window
because say it is a harder Marshall
problem to
solve all right so we
have we have e
from
okay go your
home that's what's going to happen every
time and he has a lot of skill but this
is harder okay and you can feel the
bracing angle the shortness of it okay
um and that's just with
katak um
so if your UK goes out off the line and
you're I'm sorry your Nog goes out off
the line and your
UK did not go go blasting
in then they weren't spinally displacing
there just no way
okay
um so we're going to play with that you
guys play with it okay uh let's get it
going e
[Music]
Okay so so you
no on the first one your elbow back
smash the only reason my elbows got
smash is I'm pushing up
him you then reacted to it don't get
smashed with now you're jerking out of
there cuz you're like go faster the
window's smaller you get it's all it's
all
illusion because he he's pushing where
it doesn't matter it never mattered it
never
mattered you understand do you get what
I mean by I said it doesn't matter cuz
it's going in me right okay so you just
like you could stop everything you can
stop everything you can decide how much
he he
moved and because that doesn't matter
this doesn't matter either
which is why as you watch it doesn't
look like he's driving and maybe those
at patreon they also think he's not
driving because it doesn't look like he
is but he is
okay um and then the difference
is as it doesn't matter I can I control
the rate that he's going this is where I
this is where I was doing so here you're
trying
to get to his speed but you want to
control the rate that he's go that he's
going you see so you don't go late got
to go faster you don't you don't do that
you make
connection okay and so you could slow
him down to a stop where it doesn't look
like he's driving at all okay and so as
it doesn't look like he's
driving um likewise if he's pushing
and I can do it it's the technique gets
easier because that's the Tactical
opening for the technique it doesn't get
harder it gets easier but if I can't do
the internals it does get harder okay
and I won't know that
unless I task him with it okay and so it
he he goes the technique gets easier all
the forces get
easier because y value goes up the Y
value goes
up everything gets
easier okay that's what we're trying to
get
to
um so we'll keep playing with it and
we're trying to lose the
distinction you see the dichotomy is is
delusion it's illusion and when my
technique doesn't
change whether he
goes static drop driving or even pulling
you've seen me do all of those you see
but the hardest one is the driving
because of what it does to the ego
tripartite mind and how
dependent the internals are for that
mind to
be
deconstructed okay we'll try some more
right lot of shoulder
tension your breathing is not fluid
[Music]
one more spiral
good you'll see that video your shoulder
goes right up you're trying to stop him
that's different from internalizing when
I internalize I'm not stopping him he's
still driving okay try it again three
more and then we got out Yang that
[Music]
time back in the shoulder
okay so moreon spinal
displacement um
something I haven't really said overtly
okay but again you you can't really
learn this by salad barring me you have
to salad bar your Japanese Shihan
because they don't have a full
meal but this is a system everything
goes
together so
my idea you want to learn it you're
going to have to engage you're going to
have to engage with the teacher you
can't
just pick
things try to bring them into what
you're
doing
[Music]
so looking at kihon waza from the
Marshall
component I know I need this spinal
displacement and if you pay attention
all the Kon waza
will always
throw with the
inertia going
forward towards me the reason for this
is if the opponent's inertia is going
backwards away from
me there's no throw there's no reason to
throw I will draw my
handgun because you created the time
space for weapon
deployment so it makes sense to everyone
when the person takes one of the front
inward kazushi patterns that they were
coming
forward but the same would apply for the
person that is doing the rear outward
kazushi patterns they have to be coming
forward they're not going backwards so
I'm not accelerating them backwards they
have to be going
forward that's important
and this remains true even when we get
to the
ushida
[Music]
theed those are all spinal
displacements in a pull but when I throw
the UK the UK has to be going
forward always even if they're at the
rear outward or rear inward K patters
have to be going forward okay
this allows for two types of
bumi and because there's two types of
throws there is what I call an inertial
throw which I do mostly if I do them I
do them in
guaza but if I'm teaching and I'm trying
to get the whole system into my dashing
we use the x pattern and we utilize the
base displacement because it requires
more ground vectoring and mid and
midfoot
weighting uh timing so we're going to do
that but this not the only way of
throwing someone into the rear inward or
rear
outward you can generate an x pattern so
to speak
inertially where you use the forward
momentum of the their
assault to prevent the feet from going
backwards so that they cannot put their
base of support back under their line of
gravity so I don't have the problem we
always raise with the acceleration throw
if I Tas them going forward they can't
step going
backwards not possible just as if I step
behind their leg
they can't step going
backwards so when we
do a chin strike throw for
example you have to have all this in
mind and the two types of
ukemi are if we take the x pattern with
the spinal displacement you have to do
the Contracting Center back brake P but
if we do the
inertial displacement you you have to
slide forward there's no way you you're
going to slide forward because you're
going to be coming forward okay uh and
that's what's happening in this thrum
okay so
uh let us trade the
camera and let us look at what this
means okay
okay also use this north south line on
the mat Chris go over there at that end
you see this mat between this okay and
uh I'll just show it not from The Kino
nag because that doesn't really change
anything okay if we plot his spine in
space I don't want to
enter and then shove his head
backwards because as you saw him do he
would just walk his base of
support back under his line of gravity
and neutralize the kazushi angle the
angle disturbance from the strik on his
chin what happens in most iido land is
for some reason he pins his feet there
and I get to push his chin back far
enough to where it makes sense for his
body to fall but what never makes sense
is why did you leave your feet
there okay and so you can see there's
nothing I'm doing to stop him from
moving his feet back with
him in which case his line of gravity
will never fall out of his face of
support and there's no reason to fall
okay now you could make this a full-on
palm heel strike but that's not a throw
that's an attempt at
unconsciousness then you get lights out
and he will fall okay but that's not the
technique so what I'm saying here is you
can do this technique with the spinal
displacement so I've come out and I'll
move this
way now he can't step
there and this is what what we've done a
lot of so
w attacking the leg
okay
um let's do that same side from this
angle all right step
out so the Koshi is on the back of his
leg
here going through the
base the AR the hand on the head is
doing the same pattern we always do for
the back outward so that means don't
shove it here bring it into the adhesion
Circle attack leg that what I'm calling
that ense say Yin yield because he did
it all the time
okay um
so again here
contact turn
him
leg hey we're going to try that
version okay so I just asked I they just
felt my technique Taylor felt it as the
uko and I just threw Chris and I I asked
them what did you feel in my technique
and Chris is
commenting that the whole interchange
the whole partnership is softer until
the throw and the throw is not soft okay
and so let's pay attention to that part
that is very important
okay okay so if you look at the first
version which is just totally wrong when
I shove him he would feel that strength
you feel that that's what doesn't feel
soft okay and if you look at
it it's because there is a there's an
inertia meaning his body is right now at
rest and when I push it I am contesting
the restfulness of that position and
that feels not soft to the UK
okay that's contestation I'm not
accepting that right now he's resting
I'm trying to overpower it okay when we
do the other one we task him with spinal
displacement so his chin is moving
forward if his Chin's moving forward and
I HED you're going to get the same
contestation it does not feel slof
okay um what I have to do instead is
through the internalization control the
rate at which he's able to come forward
okay so excuse
me he can't push forward no matter how
hard he pushes forward he can't push
forward it doesn't matter when I'm
moving and I touch him here so I'm
touching him here but this hand is
what's controlling is R now I move the
whole
thing to the neutral yarn you see that
okay
so I control the
rate touch I'm moving now off the line
but he still can't go forward because
you have the same elbow check the two
hands now not going to go here and now
overpower and go going to circle this
whole
thing so I'm going to take it to neutral
Yang and then turn it
around like this
okay he really
dying
pop and that's the softness that that
you're feeling okay so careful
don't just go here cuz oh you're going
to get stuck
again going to turn you want to turn his
whole body turn his whole
body to open the leg okay let's try it
let's watch
that I'm going to plot your your head in
space and how far it go go ahead touch
we on the
line all right so you almost got to to
this line right there almost a full 2
m you you first touched his head at at
this line and
then you let go of his head at this line
so you you push back 2 MERS do you get
that and I'm not sure where I go but it
starts to look like you're
pushing him okay so
you you got his head here you see and
then you pushed his
head to this line
right and when I that to
me it starts to go Yong it starts to go
Yong you see and what I'm going to do
here is go this
way so I'm on the same neutral Y Line do
you see that
so you're
here you're all and then you
went yeah you can I can feel it I can
feel it
okay and what I'm going to do instead is
be back
here and I stay here and my only goal on
the spinal
displacement is
this right you see that with forward
progress that's your only mark goal your
Martial goal is not to do this and line
of Gravity Falls outside
so boom
bo then the leg is
available okay let's try it right all
right so we had Chris try it and all all
he did was come back here and then
shove he kept the line thing but in my
description I said all I need is for him
to tilt and keep his forward inertia and
so when you shoving him backwards where
it doesn't feel soft anymore he he's not
still coming forward I'm trying to
accelerate his head backwards that's
what you're doing instead so instead I'm
I'm using his his y displacement here
that's what I'm using to make that go
go and so you can see as we increase the
the spinal
displacement the center comes up right
did you see that did you see that
the center comes up and now we're
doing the same
throw we always
do we
don't accelerate this we let this thing
start rotating around this way so the
legs come up and we start to Circle it
around the centrifugal energy as the
legs are coming up going around it
starts to bring the head down and that's
the fall that's the Thro okay and again
like in the beginning of this video the
harder it comes in if I'm doing it right
the easier the technique not the harder
the technique that's why I'm doing it
wrong I'm Yong Ying things okay all
right so try to try to keep his forward
progress try to keep letting his Center
his feet go past you not trying to
accelerate the top of that Joe back the
other way okay all right we're going to
play with it
right okay
so e
we going
here cool you see plotted in
space got it then it goes
out moved away from me he then comes
back
he if I need him to go
forward this hand doesn't ever go that
direction all right just like eel right
I want him
to I I don't want to push him
away it's it's inverse because we're on
the front inward so I this hand goes
around me all
right say
time this hand cannot go away from me if
this hand goes away from me then that
elbow is out there so likewise
when I go
here that's that's where he's
pushing so that hand slips goes this way
okay do it again here's here's his
energy I don't want to contest it so I
don't want to take even doing the distal
lever that's just external leverage okay
I don't contest it it goes around me
this way all right then he keeps going
forward so if you
watch his spine as we go his he keeps
going forward into the
technique I go like this kind of stop
okay so I do make
contact but no energy goes that way and
no energy stops all energy keeps going
in the direction that he's
going right see that okay all right
let's try it and uh Ian you doing this
you bring in your hand back forward all
your people are okay try
it you so it looks
like you two are doing this it looks
looks like
you uh get this
hand in this pulling that and I don't I
don't do that so
his
his inertia that he's using here is
telling me how far this hand and where
it has to go so stay where you are so
there's a lot of pressure there right
you see
that just like there would be a lot of
pressure here do you feel do you feel
that so this is telling me that pressure
there I have to take it to where it goes
off you
see do you feel that yes okay so I think
when you guys try to throw you're
throwing with the
obvious that kind of thing and what I'm
throwing
with is the
inertia the inertia that's turning him
this this forward progress that's what
I'm throwing
not his skin suit okay so let's bring
some awareness you should not feel his
fingers of which all that you feel is
that there's a mass going
here there's a mask
going and I'm string here and here do
you see and what I do is make it go like
that that's all I feel don't pull on the
limbs okay try to turn the body you
always throw the
body even if we are in the limb we're in
the body in this case we've done what
mid-range grappling almost always does
start at the wrist pass through to the
spine fin line that's what you do all
the time in this case I'm not I'm
bypassing the elbow but not really
because it's in that first check do you
see and then you're back on the spine we
just do it over and over and over again
so that means we're
throwing the whole body and that means
the inertia that I feel of the spinal
displacement Bo that is what I'm turning
and when I start pulling on it then I'm
not using the forward energy that's
coming forward I'm trying to pull on the
extremities of the spine doesn't work
okay try it again
so
this means that the UK is never going to
be able to turn
around and do a forward roll
if my UK is doing that there's only two
ways that can
happen the one way
is I
am contesting at the head and contesting
at the grip and bringing this all like
that because their Center is now not
being occupied with the forward progress
you stop their forward progress that's
going to give them back back their
ability to rotate on the basis the
single basic support and you don't want
that that's not the technique okay the
only other way is that the UK does not
spinally
displace per the technique so the person
I will go like this you see and there
there's no attack there that's not it
okay so what I do is I tell UK you have
to spinally displace and now let him get
there let him get
there and then I can't control it so I
don't kill
them and give them that sense of feeling
and usually they're afraid of the x
pattern so I don't do it as much I'll do
more of the inertial
throw um but then eventually
as you as you two know that I've that's
enough of you and I I throw you in the x
pattern okay then we're back to that oh
how do you want to land that's your
that's your choice there okay sooner or
later you know all your UK have to be
brought to that point but let's make it
later for your UK because maybe they
haven't done the ground work for the
Contracting Center back break ball we
don't want to hurt anyone okay so just
tell your UK
to keep coming
forward without
you pushing them backwards where they
would be motivated to turn then the two
of you meet in the
center uh you know so to speak and they
will keep coming forward and it's a back
breakfall but it is forward of the
spinal displacement okay and that's if
for doing the the uh the uh base
displacement x pattern okay if if
they're coming in really really fast
which tends to happen for me in guaza
then this whole thing is out here you
don't need the base the legs come up on
their own and it's the exact same throw
but they go even more forward into the
technique which we're not going to show
tonight we this took a while but I think
everyone learned something here okay
lots to work on pay attention to that
Yin yield everyone who's going to watch
this because you're going to just shove
their head backwards uh you're not going
to keep their forward progress you're
not going to be spiral rotating the
forward inertia of this final
displacement you're going to tend to
pull on the head push on the head pull
on the wrist and that's just not the
technique that stuff just does not
function when somebody's trying to
actually attack you with this technique
with some sort of on you can't throw
people by pulling their limbs that's
just La La Land okay and it's not not
mid-range grappling